warning this video may make you
extremely pregnant house come respite
spare to pack
welcome to realistic kissing the
simulator I like how they put realistic
in there
that's what do you know is gotta be good
it's also a two-player game so I'm
playing this alone which is it a little
sad you're gonna play with me you can't
all right so you start by holding down
these two alright that is cute that's
cute
what the [ __ ] would you like to kiss me
invite to kiss what happens as I say no
no what what what great best game ever
I would rate this 10 out of 10 I think
that's a little too low actually 11 out
of 10 this game doesn't have any music I
need to fix this come on there we go get
him to mood
this our dance at the club to find women
so I got mites yes anyway let's sexually
[ __ ] play this game yes I would like
to kiss you I mean who wouldn't like to
kiss that beautiful place that looks
identical to you that winning house I
can't I'm sorry I just had a yes yeah
I'm pretty if she never kissed anyone
trust me this game is about 99% accurate
oh yeah you like when I lick your
nostrils you like that [ __ ] dare to me
why was it a wind when I kissed my own
nostrils what if what the actual [ __ ] ah
yeah go in go in
oh yeah I didn't push me away on it oh
no she went for the kiss her spell
goddamn it this is actually very simple
although the tongue becomes smaller oh
god what is happening
oh nice I'm doing this is yeah now we're
talking baby that's right hmm you want
to keep your eyes open as well and not
make eye contact
oh yeah yeah wait wait you're going let
me play with your lips the real question
is can I lick her eye
oh god that's not an eye oh that's my
eye all right yeah she's hesitating a
little bit come here honey come here
honey
can't you worry it's gonna be a good up
that what why why does all my other
things not work then I don't understand
at all maybe I'm missing the point here
I don't know all right oh now my eye
come on let me lick your eye oh yeah let
me lick your eye come on baby oh oh my
god this is the greatest game of all
time of all years of all futures my god
my life has been lived up to this moment
nothing will ever be oh I'm licking my
own eye now oh it feels so good just
love teasing my soul now I'm going back
to you baby
that's rad you can have some too all
right back to me back to you back to me
back to you god I'm such a tease our day
yeah oh yeah oh yeah you like it when I
like it like that baby you like it when
I lick your eye yah oh yah oh yah oh yah
oh yeah that's right oh yeah you want to
lick your nostril to listen lick it
together baby come on let me lick it
never take it oh God oh yeah you go
underneath there I used I store food
there sometimes if you find some tacos
don't be oh this tastes so good honey
no no no don't don't be scared honey
this is yeah that's right come closer
now yeah you like it don't you you like
it when I lick your nose let me lick my
own nose now
oh god ah ah this time you're so sexy
what I didn't even kiss anyone how is
that a victory
how have I played this game for five
minutes can I go down her throat
not that I would want to okay don't do
that kids so yeah if this video doesn't
get flag and I won't be surprised at all
tongues can make weird shapes I learned
that today I actually have a pretty long
time you what he why am I not winning I
don't understand but okay you know what
best game ever 10/10 IGN yes alright so
if you haven't kissed anyone I highly
recommend trying this game out it's in
the description thanks for playing thank
you I think we did a great job I think
that what we learned here is really how
you you kissed someone so if you have
never kissed anyone or you want some
extra practice I highly recommend this
game I check it out in bigger
description sleeve like have you learned
how to kiss and I'll see you in the next
video stay awesome bros love you not
enough to kiss you maybe in this game
sometimes